i think there's quite a lot of shock
over here in the uk that prince harry
went as far as he did
i've experienced pain or suffering
because of the pain or suffering that
perhaps my
father or my parents suffered he's
treating me the way that he was treated
i'm gonna make sure that i break that
cycle there's a lot of genetic
pain and suffering that gets passed on i
think the podcast certainly raised
eyebrows over at the palace
to have prince harry so soon after
trying to build bridges
quite openly criticize his father and
possibly even his grandparents
is quite surprising just when the ice
was seemingly starting to thaw in the
royal rift
harry's armchair expert podcast
interview could freeze over
efforts between the truman show and
being in a zoo it does seem that this is
yet
another example of prince harry
criticizing his father who of course
came under some fire in that oprah
interview my family
literally cut me off financially hold up
wait a minute
your family cut you off yeah my
understanding is that
both with the oprah interview and this
recent podcast
a prince harry feels both of them have
gone down very well
he predicted and anticipated there would
be this
type of backlash in the british press
[Music]
everyone is wondering will the brothers
be standing shoulder by shoulder on july
the 1st for the unveiling of the diana
statue
of course a lot of it depends on when
his daughter is born there's been no
comment from buckingham palace
my whole life whether it be long or so
shall be devoted to your service
she is the longest reigning monarch in
history think about that and she has put
duty before everything i spoke with
gayle king who will
explore the extraordinary life and reign
of queen elizabeth tonight in her cbs
special
the queen carries on we were looking to
talk to people
who had been knighted by the queen so
paul mccartney
she must like you paul could be i like
her
he's received many awards from the queen
so he does feel a connection to her
how do you think she'll move on without
philip he really was the love of her
life you know they met when she was very
young
she will move on because she really is
the ultimate of
keep calm and carry on